well a powerful earthquake in indonesia
has killed at least 35 people and
injured hundreds more
the quake struck at night on the island
of sulawesi
claiming lives and damaging many
buildings in and around the capital
district
now authorities fear more people could
be buried in the rubble and
they're warning that strong aftershocks
could also
trigger a tsunami
trapped under the rubble this person
tells rescue workers she can barely hear
the woman next to her breathing
the powerful quake struck just after
midnight
causing many to flee in the darkness
in the morning those left in the hardest
hit city of mamuju woke up to scenes
like these
this is what was left of the local
hospital where a rescue operation is now
underway
as you can see behind me from this
hospital
we have retrieved two dead victims
we are still trying to find more victims
in the rubble
but we don't know yet if they are still
alive
or not
some people have been recovered from the
debris
but it's a vast operation as many as
half the buildings in mamuju city have
either collapsed or are partially
damaged
and there are fears that strong
aftershocks are still to come
aftershocks are still happening
according to our analysis
from local data that we'd recorded as
well as historical data
we believe there's still potential for
more strong
aftershocks just like what happened at
midnight
[Music]
for now many fearing the aftershocks are
choosing to stay on high ground
wondering if they'll have homes to go
back to
from jakarta i'm joined now by dw
correspondent
priyadani to apuba thank you so much for
joining us
what is the latest right now
yes sarah it is certainly um one of the
most challenging time here in indonesia
because we're still in the middle of a
plane crash
investigation and now we are facing a
massive earthquake
in the eastern part of indonesia so what
can i say to you right now is the
rescue team is still carrying out
the rest opportunity to find survive
and who are trapped under the rubble and
there are two worst affected locations
in that area which is
majenne district and mamuju district and
in this two location
at least 34 people died because of this
earthquake
so the rescue team has also faced
a little bit of obstacles because there
was also rain
in there and the electricity is still
out
and the communication cellular is still
also unstable so the rescue team is
still
do their job to really find the
survivors
as soon as possible yeah and we're
looking at those images right now like
as you've mentioned
that that you know the rain that has
been an issue a challenge
for um for for authorities as they try
and move in there for for rescue workers
there's also the fear of aftershocks as
well given all of those factors how
are the rescue operations taking place
yes sure um the head of the
meteorological and geophysics
agency here in indonesia in a news
conference has told
us that aftershocks is
still potentially happening and it could
lead to a tsunami
so c urge the people to
really stay away from areas that has a
lot of buildings
and structures that are easily collapsed
and also to stay
away from the coastal area to go to the
higher ground
but still up until now the rescue
operation is still
do their job to really find victims and
also survivors
which are trapped under the rubbles
because
um as being reported um dozens of houses
are
destroyed even the office of the
governor himself
is also destroyed at this
massive earthquake sarah thank you so
much dw's prie hardani to apoora
reporting from jakarta on this
earthquake in indonesia we appreciate it
you